[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Third well, son.
[SPEAKER_04]: Just after midnight, the group is in the inner sanctum.
[SPEAKER_04]: Paul Ribeiro comes out of this trance, this little clay lizard, scattering around the side.
[SPEAKER_02]: Holy shit, guys, we got him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, Farrowin, yeah, he's gone.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's evil.
[SPEAKER_02]: He is in there talking to Tutoly right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: What does Tutoly look like?
[SPEAKER_01]: I need to know if they're wizards or are they fighters?
[SPEAKER_04]: They were not wearing armor.
[SPEAKER_04]: They carried swords and daggers.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, there could be nobility, but...
[SPEAKER_02]: So there is a hobgoblin right there across the door and then it goes down and then right to the left.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I can try to use my toad to just see if I can bring that hobgoblin around the corner to us closer.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna lay on the floor.
[SPEAKER_01]: The crossbow?
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me just try to do this.
[SPEAKER_01]: I need you ready to assassinate the hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to send my toad right out here in whatever the shiniest part of the floor is where he can be and I'm just going to have him do it.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you guys crack the door open slightly.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you're sitting there with your crossbow.
[SPEAKER_03]: So Paul has something clear above me, so I'm gonna lay down.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you can fire above me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so the three of you are sitting down like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is a hobgoblin in heavy armor, and I have a dagger that does great against guys in heavy armor.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do we want him to shoot with a crossbow?
[SPEAKER_03]: I think we take both an assassination shot.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, just talk about both of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: One of us should be able to drop him if we both hit him.
[SPEAKER_01]: If we can't kill him then... We got problems.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I just want to see if I can all look through my frog's eyes and just try to get this dude's attention.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: You kneel with your crossbow, basically on me, with your knee on me, and see if Merrick can notch right above that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so the three of you get in position to fire.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're laying, you're kneeling, and you're behind them.
[SPEAKER_04]: I want you to roll your stealth to see how...
[SPEAKER_02]: I say, remember people, I want Fairwind Alive.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Shit.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's an altogether 13.
[SPEAKER_03]: 13?
[SPEAKER_04]: That's 67.
[SPEAKER_00]: Would they have advantage?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, they do not have advantage here.
[SPEAKER_05]: 14 stealth plus 5, so... 19.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four plus?
[SPEAKER_04]: Four plus 6.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ten, okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So...
[SPEAKER_04]: Your frog goes to there and starts riveting.
[SPEAKER_03]: There's your frog.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's green.
[SPEAKER_03]: Two eyes.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's looking that way.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's a ward on his head.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so he just starts croaking.
[SPEAKER_01]: I like hop around in a circle.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then I kind of like hop over here in the darkness and then I come back over here and look at him.
[SPEAKER_04]: You go down the stairs?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, I don't go down the stairs.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just go right here and then like, you know, stick my head around.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'm just acting weird.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wow, that toad is acting weird.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is strange.
[SPEAKER_01]: Out of his line of sight, back into his line of sight.
[SPEAKER_01]: If he like pulls out a crossbow, I want to know.
[SPEAKER_01]: He pulls on his blade, and he's looking over there, like a little mockingly, you know, like, I'm not kind of like, it's not a big deal.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'm laying here, you know, like, I'm a fat toad, I'm mocking you, bro, I'm mocking you.
[SPEAKER_04]: He begins walking over.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here, get a representation.
[SPEAKER_04]: Tell me, yeah, when he clears.
[SPEAKER_04]: Alright, he gets right to the edge there and stops.
[SPEAKER_04]: Does not notice Paul.
[SPEAKER_04]: Takes a couple more steps into the room.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fire.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's an advantage, by the way.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ooh, 16 for both of us.
[SPEAKER_05]: All of you have an advantage.
[SPEAKER_01]: See if you rolled a 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll again.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you rolled a 20, you're like... Twenty!
[SPEAKER_04]: Sixteen hits!
[SPEAKER_01]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Natural.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_06]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_06]: You could be rolling.
[SPEAKER_06]: You could be casting.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then it's here, powering.
[SPEAKER_06]: Vicious Mockering.
[SPEAKER_06]: I was supposed to power up.
[SPEAKER_04]: I was trying to read.
[SPEAKER_04]: 15.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you got a 16 plus your stuff.
[SPEAKER_04]: 16 plus my long goes a 7.
[SPEAKER_04]: 23.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: 1 die 8.
[SPEAKER_04]: Did you hit?
[SPEAKER_05]: I got 15.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: 3.
[SPEAKER_05]: 3 plus your 3?
[SPEAKER_04]: For what?
[SPEAKER_04]: You get your Dex modifier.
[SPEAKER_05]: You get your Dex modifier plus.
[SPEAKER_05]: Plus three CS, six.
[SPEAKER_05]: Six points of damage, okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Why they're doing that, can I cast Divine Stance?
[SPEAKER_06]: Did I get an attack bonus too?
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure, if you want to.
[SPEAKER_04]: Your attack bonus is plus your attack bonus.
[SPEAKER_04]: You got that, you put that in there, right, for your attack bonus?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes, it was seven.
[SPEAKER_05]: Plus seven, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: 23.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes, yes, yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you do six points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: You got a 20.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you're sink attacking.
[SPEAKER_04]: Assassinating.
[SPEAKER_03]: Three die six, six die six, and two die ten.
[SPEAKER_03]: Two die ten plus four.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where's my other ten?
[SPEAKER_03]: There it is.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then I need how many sixes again?
[SPEAKER_03]: Six die six.
[SPEAKER_03]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: You got it?
[SPEAKER_03]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nine, ten, eighteen, twenty, twenty-nine.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you rolled a fifteen total?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh wait, I didn't put the plus four.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's one nine ten plus four so that would be on both of them plus another eight makes it thirty-seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's only 39 because you don't ever double that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, don't double the plus star?
[SPEAKER_03]: You don't double that, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Although I was adding 4 to each 10, but it didn't work that way.
[SPEAKER_03]: You don't add 4 to each 10.
[SPEAKER_04]: You only add the 4 to the end of it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Your bolt rings off his breastplate.
[SPEAKER_04]: No damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Basically two, an arrow hits him and goes through his armor and your bolt sticks him right here.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he's like, he calls out.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's not down.
[SPEAKER_04]: He goes, ahhh, and yells something out in hobgoblin.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then drops to the ground.
[SPEAKER_04]: Bleeding out.
[SPEAKER_04]: You hear in the room back there, people shouting.
[SPEAKER_04]: Out here?
[SPEAKER_04]: Back in that area, over there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Not over here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Not over there.
[SPEAKER_04]: What do you guys want to do?
[SPEAKER_04]: You want to do rush in, or do you want to stay right where you're at?
[SPEAKER_03]: Move!
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm going in.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going in, I'm getting up, pulling my blades.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going with my hands.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, let's do combat.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy's dead right here.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm in the front.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gouge, you are right here?
[SPEAKER_03]: They're in the front, unless he stepped on us.
[SPEAKER_04]: Merrick is right here, and is this you, Paul?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're right there.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're right there, Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is you, Jude, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Who are we missing?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, we have everyone now.
[SPEAKER_04]: You guys went.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to jump up and move forward, Gouge?
[SPEAKER_03]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_04]: Jump up from prone.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's half your movement.
[SPEAKER_04]: So one, two, three.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fifteen to there.
[SPEAKER_04]: How about you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I want to go in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that's half his movement.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can he dash if he wanted to?
[SPEAKER_01]: He could dash if he wanted to.
[SPEAKER_01]: And go another fifteen?
[SPEAKER_04]: Another thirty if he wanted to.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I got the weapons out, and I can stay in the hallway, so let's push it.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you turn the corner?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm going to take it.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's going to be your bonus action, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you want that.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, one, two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to keep going?
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to go to here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you run through there.
[SPEAKER_04]: And look down that hall.
[SPEAKER_03]: Staying covered, peeking down the hall.
[SPEAKER_03]: See how far everyone can get with you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Opening there.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And so you hold.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is blocked, too.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you hold an action?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm holding.
[SPEAKER_04]: You hold an action?
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to move?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, don't they have cutting action that allows me to... Gash with your bonus action.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then, um, let me...
[SPEAKER_02]: What is this?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, these are doors.
[SPEAKER_04]: Five?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, this is like openings.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Into the... You know how you got ready enough?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I'm just ready right here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you're ready to action with what?
[SPEAKER_04]: Crossbow?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, crossbow.
[SPEAKER_04]: So if you see somebody, you'll shoot them?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Uh, you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Go ahead.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to have ready action with your bow?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you just have your bow ready?
[SPEAKER_04]: Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sword and shield.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll go ahead and gash right up to the very... One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_06]: Right in front of him.
[SPEAKER_06]: In front of everybody.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five, six to here?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's your action, not a bonus action.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, scoop up my frog.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's your bonus action?
[SPEAKER_03]: 1, 2, 3, 4... You can't dash.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to ready your action and just stay?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll scoop up my frog in my pocket and ready.
[SPEAKER_04]: Can I see with my homocular in the room?
[SPEAKER_04]: You can if you want to move him there.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, he came back.
[SPEAKER_01]: I had to come back?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you said he was on your shoulder.
[SPEAKER_01]: You didn't stop him when he said that he came back.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Or do you want to stay back?
[SPEAKER_01]: Where do you want to go?
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to be at us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, Adrian, real quick, I want to actually ready an action, and if somebody comes up from this stairway.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're covering the stairs.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'm covering the stairs with my wand, mentioned muscle.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to say cover the rear or something.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I'll... Can't you cast like a portal to nowhere and people just fall through?
[SPEAKER_03]: It would be nice, yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can't you levitate them?
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, let's see.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does the door... Do we want to keep the door open?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, great point.
[SPEAKER_00]: Close the door behind us and lock it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does it have a bar or anything behind?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: While going in...
[SPEAKER_06]: I'd say leave that door open because the other two are barred already.
[SPEAKER_06]: Then there's nobody behind it.
[SPEAKER_03]: This one's barred, that one's barred.
[SPEAKER_06]: Right, so if we need a place to escape too, that might be a good place to leave.
[SPEAKER_00]: Everything else is barred?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I'll keep it open then.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there any way I can be in touching range of Jude?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or am I just out of reach?
[SPEAKER_00]: You're just five feet away.
[SPEAKER_04]: What did you want to do?
[SPEAKER_04]: I was going to try to enhance ability on Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which is in touch range.
[SPEAKER_00]: I see.
[SPEAKER_04]: Actually, you could move to there.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think you just moved four, so if you wanted to move to here you could do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Would it be beneficial to cast Enhanced because it says for foxes coming the target has advantage on intelligent checks?
[SPEAKER_00]: Would that be useful during combat with intelligent checks?
[SPEAKER_04]: Not normally.
[SPEAKER_01]: You'd probably want to cast that in around the dumb members.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think that would be like if you're in a library looking for Tsukasa, or trying to figure out a mechanism or something like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: You'd want to put enhanceability.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, in that case, I'll stay there and then I'm going to give Bardic inspiration.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who, you're a bard?
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: I am a bard.
[SPEAKER_00]: You didn't get the joke in me?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna cast a bardic inspiration on Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_04]: Tyrus, for the next 10 minutes, you can use a 1 die 6 on any ability attack roll that you can do.
[SPEAKER_06]: Is that 2 hit?
[SPEAKER_04]: Damage is not damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: If he becomes a Bard of Battle, Valor, you can do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Alright, so you guys run to there.
[SPEAKER_04]: From inside the room, you hear, Ho!
[SPEAKER_04]: Who goes there?
[SPEAKER_03]: Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge, Gouge,
[SPEAKER_01]: No, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, it might still fucking work, dude.
[SPEAKER_04]: We have Lord Fairwind in here, and you will kill him if you try to attack us.
[SPEAKER_04]: Give us your names.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do we spend a turn with evil, though?
[SPEAKER_05]: He's working with them.
[SPEAKER_05]: Don't worry.
[SPEAKER_05]: They'll bless him.
[SPEAKER_05]: So you're like, that's your life.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I'm not.
No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't kill our Lord!
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, we'll keep, we'll buy, we'll buy, we'll buy a sign, you know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Who are you?
[SPEAKER_01]: You're my heiress.
[SPEAKER_02]: Show yourself.
[SPEAKER_02]: You first.
[SPEAKER_04]: You say you first?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I look like a hobgoblin.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can get blasted.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can walk up there.
[SPEAKER_06]: Ball of steel, my friend.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anybody got a keel?
[SPEAKER_01]: How long does that... Bardic Inspiration?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I think he said it was two minutes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two minutes is a lifetime in combat.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I mean, they know them.
[SPEAKER_06]: All right, so... Detect evil.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that lasts pretty long.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, detect or protect from evil?
[SPEAKER_06]: Detect.
[SPEAKER_06]: I thought I had that.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's what you see.
[SPEAKER_03]: You go to there?
[SPEAKER_03]: So I can see in, well, there's a door or an opening, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Hall and hall and another opening, okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: A guy standing right there?
[SPEAKER_04]: Mm-hmm.
Bulk.
[SPEAKER_04]: From a hand crossbow.
[SPEAKER_04]: Shoots right at you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hits you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I use the uncanny dodge?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: What does that do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Does that add to your armor class?
[SPEAKER_01]: To like, or does it minimize damage?
[SPEAKER_01]: Two?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so I have 100% sugar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I look it up a little clip on my phone?
[SPEAKER_03]: Handbook.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two, six points of damage to you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: The bolt streaks out and skims your face.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to use uncanny dodge?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Only take three points of damage?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Take it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, is it just taken?
[SPEAKER_04]: I have to roll.
[SPEAKER_04]: You don't have to roll.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: You just lose three points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you dodge back, but you take three points of damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll a constitution saving throw.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't have a good con.
[SPEAKER_04]: What's your constitution saving throw bonus?
[SPEAKER_03]: Con saving throw bonus.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's out of there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Plus two.
[SPEAKER_03]: Con's fourteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Seventeen.
[SPEAKER_03]: You make it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Luckily.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: Anish.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: All of us roll.
[SPEAKER_03]: And let me start with Gouge, what do you got?
[SPEAKER_03]: Eleven plus four is fifteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four plus anything?
[SPEAKER_04]: Two.
[SPEAKER_04]: Six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Twenty plus two, so twenty-two.
[SPEAKER_00]: Twenty-two for Folsum.
[SPEAKER_05]: Merrick?
[SPEAKER_05]: Five plus three, eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eight?
[SPEAKER_04]: Merrick gets eight?
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty-two.
[SPEAKER_04]: Add your dex bonus or anything else you have?
[SPEAKER_02]: Plus 4, 18.
[SPEAKER_01]: 18?
[SPEAKER_01]: Q.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus 4.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus 4, 5.
[SPEAKER_03]: Permanently 1.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's just going like this.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh shit!
[SPEAKER_03]: Sorry buddy!
[SPEAKER_03]: Get off your phone!
[SPEAKER_03]: You did a great job, you did a great job.
[SPEAKER_01]: You got the big bad guy out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here's Q1.
[SPEAKER_01]: 13.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nineteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: The other guy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Four.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_03]: What guy's on me?
[SPEAKER_03]: Folsum, you're first.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, I will move behind Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, he's going to probably be moving, and you probably take the spot he's at.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, but he moves first.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to cast Bear's Endurance, which is an enhance ability on Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_00]: You get two d6 of hit points during it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me just find it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, that's nice.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's really good.
[SPEAKER_03]: He gets six to two dice, six and half points.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_03]: For a certain amount of time.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll be fine with this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, so then it wears off.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, you know, he's dead now.
[SPEAKER_00]: That goes off in damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: The target has advantage on constitution checks.
[SPEAKER_00]: It also gains two d6 temporary hit points, which are lost from the spell heads.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And how long do you spell?
[SPEAKER_00]: One out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who rolls the hits?
[SPEAKER_01]: He'll lose the hit points way before an hour spell.
[SPEAKER_01]: He rolls his hit points.
[SPEAKER_03]: Two down six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ten hit points.
[SPEAKER_01]: Awesome.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you've gone.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two to there.
[SPEAKER_04]: He runs up to you, Gouge, and attacks you.
[SPEAKER_04]: First attack, what's Tracy?
[SPEAKER_03]: Sixteen, but wait, I might not be having my leather armor, so it actually might be fifteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because I think that 16 is taking into account my normal leather I'm wearing, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, are you wearing the scale?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, I'm wearing a studded.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: He pulls out a reindeer with his bonus action and attacks you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here's the attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: Three.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ooh, what's your AC?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's fifteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fifteen?
[SPEAKER_02]: He misses.
[SPEAKER_04]: Luckily, you managed to dodge his attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: He attacks again.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thirteen plus nine.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: One die eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Six plus seven is thirteen points of damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I use Uncanny Dodge?
[SPEAKER_03]: You can.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's your only reaction, so you take seven points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you describe the guy that's talking to him?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I can.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's basically not wearing any armor.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's wearing nobility clothing.
[SPEAKER_01]: One of the Toli guys?
[SPEAKER_01]: And he has a rapier.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's got blondish hair, but he looks very sewer, to say the latest.
[SPEAKER_03]: That guy's gone.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, Paul.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I...
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to...
[SPEAKER_02]: I can move through Tyrants, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, then I'd like to get into that doorway with my dagger.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five, six...
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to do that?
[SPEAKER_04]: Because Gouge is right here.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can't do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can move through Gouge, but you can't move through him.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you can go one, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_04]: I want to get in close with my dagger.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I mean, do you want to go in close with that guy like toe-to-toe, like step in front of Gouge?
[SPEAKER_04]: So what you could do is you could dash around this side and attack him from behind.
[SPEAKER_04]: You could dash with your bonus action and attack him from behind.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because you get that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now does he get advantage because it's from his flank or behind?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, but he does get to synch attack if he hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you basically go around the doorway and attack the guy from behind, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Sweet.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fifteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fifteen plus six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twenty-one.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to backstab?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that is 2-6 plus your normal, and you're using your dagger?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: So 1-4 plus 2-6.
[SPEAKER_04]: 1-4 plus 2-6.
[SPEAKER_04]: 9 and 4.
[SPEAKER_04]: 13.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus their bonuses.
[SPEAKER_03]: 13.
[SPEAKER_03]: Damage bonus?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, plus 6.
[SPEAKER_02]: 19.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not plus 6, is it?
[SPEAKER_03]: For a dagger?
[SPEAKER_02]: Dagger damage mark.
[SPEAKER_02]: Plus four.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so 13 plus four is 17.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes, 17.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Alright, so Paul has gone.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do I get it?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna take both attacks.
[SPEAKER_03]: And a bonus.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you bonus.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sword and dagger.
[SPEAKER_03]: And do I still get anything else?
[SPEAKER_03]: That's my bonus attack on that.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's your bonus action.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you get an attack, and then you can do a bonus action, attack the draw hand.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll get an attack, bonus action.
[SPEAKER_03]: So this is your scimitar.
[SPEAKER_03]: Scimitar first.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does he get advantage because there's now two attackers on this guy?
[SPEAKER_03]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: He does get the sneak attack, though.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's a 7.
[SPEAKER_03]: Probably going to be a miss.
[SPEAKER_03]: Plus 9 is 16.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did you hit him Joe?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: 16?
[SPEAKER_03]: That is a hit.
[SPEAKER_02]: I did 17 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: And so that cutlass is 1 die 6 plus 6.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you want to use your sneak attack on this one?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, on this one.
[SPEAKER_03]: So 1 die 6 plus 6 and then my sneak is plus...
[SPEAKER_03]: Three dice at three.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fucker.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eleven, twelve, thirteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thirteen plus six is nineteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sixteen plus twenty, thirty-six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Dagger.
[SPEAKER_04]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gouge is gone.
[SPEAKER_04]: Next one is Merrick.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh wait, no.
[SPEAKER_05]: Totally number two.
[SPEAKER_04]: Guy comes from here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Attacks you.
[SPEAKER_04]: At advantage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twelve plus nine is twenty-one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hits you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Does 3 plus 7, 10 points of damage to you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Attacks you again with his rapier.
[SPEAKER_04]: Not at advantage.
[SPEAKER_04]: 17.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hits you again.
[SPEAKER_04]: Does 1 plus 7, 8 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: You take 18 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Uncanny dodge?
[SPEAKER_04]: So he's like, he does not have uncanny dodge yet.
[SPEAKER_03]: He has to be 5th level.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, so you take 18 points of damage, Paul.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's great.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to know how to create a kid.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm like, ugh.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can't disengage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I can.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, it's your turn, Merrick.
[SPEAKER_05]: I cast Longstride on myself.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: As a bonus section?
[SPEAKER_05]: It's an action.
[SPEAKER_05]: An action?
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Then I can move after that, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Correct.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where are you trying to get to?
[SPEAKER_03]: Back here.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, one, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_03]: I get two more.
[SPEAKER_03]: Seven, eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to pull out your sword?
[SPEAKER_04]: Or do you want to keep your bow out?
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm going to keep my bow out.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can't dash to go to here and then attack?
[SPEAKER_05]: No action.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, so the next one is Tyrus, Jude is last.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, um, I'm gonna go, I don't know, yeah, one, two, three.
[SPEAKER_06]: Don't jam that doorway up for me.
[SPEAKER_06]: I know.
[SPEAKER_06]: One, two, three.
[SPEAKER_06]: Can I push Gouge out of the way?
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, you could shove Gouge.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, shove Gouge.
[SPEAKER_06]: Shove Gouge.
[SPEAKER_06]: But that would be your attack.
[SPEAKER_06]: That would be my attack.
[SPEAKER_06]: And, um, in
[SPEAKER_06]: Engage this guy right here.
[SPEAKER_06]: That'll be my action and everything.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll try to engage that guy there, and I will use the... Do you want to push Gouge out of the way?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I want to push Gouge out of the way.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's my action.
[SPEAKER_04]: Boom, you get hit checked.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three.
[SPEAKER_04]: So to push Gouge, you have to win on a strength check unless you just want to go.
[SPEAKER_03]: Fuck no, you ain't pushing me.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll strength to strength.
[SPEAKER_03]: Six plus your athletics, five plus athletics, six is eleven.
[SPEAKER_05]: Which athletics?
[SPEAKER_05]: Here's plus five.
[SPEAKER_05]: I can't read any of that.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's eleven?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's an even match.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's an even match.
[SPEAKER_04]: But you do not go.
[SPEAKER_06]: Does, uh, can I, uh... Oh wait!
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh no, that's not strength, it's constitution.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, do you want to keep moving though?
[SPEAKER_06]: Or do you want to just stay there?
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, can I get past that guy?
[SPEAKER_06]: I can't get past Gouge, or I can't get in the doorway.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can move past Gouge, but there's a guy right there, so you can't move past the guy, so you can't be in the same spot as Gouge.
[SPEAKER_06]: Right, but I can take Gouge's place.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you didn't shell that out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: You ran into me.
[SPEAKER_01]: You tried to check him, and he stayed firm.
[SPEAKER_06]: All right, well then I'm going to continue.
[SPEAKER_03]: He can go another three.
[SPEAKER_03]: One, two, three.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I said I was ready and like I'm watching the stairway.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I hear anything at all?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like do I hear footsteps coming up the stairway?
[SPEAKER_01]: Nothing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Nothing like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so I'm gonna move, uh, what do I get?
[SPEAKER_01]: Five, ten, fifteen, twenty, twenty-five.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I go to here, thirty, can I see that guy?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Magic missile with my lawn.
[SPEAKER_01]: You fire.
[SPEAKER_01]: You silly turd.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's an automatic hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh shit, I can't even see that.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's at the top, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: To the bottom.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, it's at the top.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's three of those.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do we have another one of those?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, it's all the way around the bottom on this one.
[SPEAKER_03]: That was a two.
[SPEAKER_03]: That was a two?
[SPEAKER_03]: Four?
[SPEAKER_03]: One of right or four?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, one of right or four.
[SPEAKER_06]: I guess that's all I got, man.
[SPEAKER_06]: All right, all right, wait.
[SPEAKER_05]: Two.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's a two on top.
[SPEAKER_05]: It was meant to be two.
[SPEAKER_05]: Two and two.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that other one was a two, but it's a plus one each time.
[SPEAKER_01]: So two, three, two, three, so that's six.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a four.
[SPEAKER_01]: Five, so eleven points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Use one slot.
[SPEAKER_01]: One slot.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll mark it off.
[SPEAKER_01]: He shields it.
[SPEAKER_01]: That was a four up top.
[SPEAKER_03]: That was a four up top.
[SPEAKER_01]: It doesn't matter.
[SPEAKER_01]: He shields it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Izzy gets a reaction, so he shields it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I yell out, he's a mage!
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Um, that is it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Initiative.
[SPEAKER_03]: Take him to the ground!
[SPEAKER_03]: Ten altogether for Gouge.
[SPEAKER_03]: You get twenty?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four for Merrick.
[SPEAKER_01]: I got twenty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, we roll initiative?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_02]: You get twenty, Paul?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I got twenty.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sixteen plus four.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, fourteen altogether.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fourteen?
[SPEAKER_02]: And Jude?
[SPEAKER_04]: Two plus four, six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Six.
[SPEAKER_04]: They get this guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's the fucker.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes!
[SPEAKER_04]: He gets eight, but still.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy gets 20.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's a couple of simos.
[SPEAKER_02]: I need to win against that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Paul, Tyrus, who wants to go first?
[SPEAKER_04]: I need out, bro.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tag me out!
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm disengaging.
[SPEAKER_02]: As a bonus action.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And where do you want to move?
[SPEAKER_04]: Get around the corner.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, you know what you could do, because you are a rogue, you can attack with your action, disengage with your bonus action, and then move.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, why not?
[SPEAKER_04]: So you're on the new guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: The guy that got you?
[SPEAKER_02]: Get the guy that's already hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you try to stab that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll your attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is a nice hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want a sneak attack?
[SPEAKER_04]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll the damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: What is that?
[SPEAKER_04]: Two die six plus a one die four.
[SPEAKER_02]: Three, three, six, two, plus strength or bonuses.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eight plus four.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus four is twelve points of damage, so forty-eight off this guy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Gouge and Paul are stabbing this dude.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, and then I'm going to disengage, and one, you're going to go this way?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, one, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Move to the other side.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, that's Paul.
[SPEAKER_06]: Tyrus?
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, you want me to go next?
[SPEAKER_04]: Either you go next, or if you want to save an action, you can, but you can move up to that guy and attack.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I want to move up to this guy.
[SPEAKER_06]: Wait, one, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_03]: One, two, three, four.
[SPEAKER_03]: Four.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're on either one there.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, so at that point, can I...
[SPEAKER_04]: If you want to use your divine power, Channel Divinity, it will, well let's see what it says, they're different for each one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Champion challenge as a bonus action.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can challenge people so they can't leave.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm going to do that to this guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can do it to anybody you want.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can do it to all of them.
[SPEAKER_06]: As a bonus action, and I will attack that guy that's on Gouge.
[SPEAKER_06]: The one that's wounded?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll attack?
[SPEAKER_04]: And what are you attacking with?
[SPEAKER_06]: My longs are 1 to 8.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And the plus you get is plus 5 to hit.
[SPEAKER_06]: Plus 5 now.
[SPEAKER_06]: To hit.
[SPEAKER_06]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: So then... 4 plus 5 is 9.
[SPEAKER_04]: You miss him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let me see what kind of a saving throw they have to make against your Channel Divinity.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_04]: The Channel Divinity spell, um...
[SPEAKER_04]: Wisdom said he'd throw.
[SPEAKER_04]: And your DC is 13, I believe.
[SPEAKER_04]: First guy, DC 13, he's got a bonus of plus 4.
[SPEAKER_04]: He makes it.
[SPEAKER_04]: The next guy...
[SPEAKER_04]: He makes it?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, he does make it.
[SPEAKER_04]: So they're not going to be affected by that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fight me!
[SPEAKER_04]: No, I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_06]: Maybe I distracted him though.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_03]: Now it's this guy right here.
[SPEAKER_03]: This guy right there.
[SPEAKER_03]: This guy attacks you.
[SPEAKER_04]: What's your AC?
[SPEAKER_04]: Uh... 18?
[SPEAKER_06]: 18.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, first attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: 12 plus 9, that hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: He does 7, 14 points of damage to you.
[SPEAKER_03]: But it's just the 10 fake ones.
[SPEAKER_04]: 14?
[SPEAKER_04]: 14 plus 7 is 21.
[SPEAKER_04]: He does 6, 7, 13 points, more points, so he does 23 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: 23 all together, okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: 10 are fake, so you got 13.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, that's it.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's his turn.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's see, who's next?
[SPEAKER_04]: That's the 20s.
[SPEAKER_04]: Uh, Folsum, you're 14.
[SPEAKER_04]: Alright, I'm going to...
[SPEAKER_00]: I am going to... run to... Paul Rivero.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: One, two, three, four...
[SPEAKER_00]: You're at him.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I think I'm going to cast Cure Wounds.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that's a 1.8 plus your charisma bonus.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus 4.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: 4 plus 4 and you get 8 hit points back, Paul.
[SPEAKER_04]: Awesome.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm not instantly a one hit, but to these guys I am.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gouge.
[SPEAKER_03]: So throwing my stones up would take away from my dagger attack.
[SPEAKER_03]: Scimitar, I'm staying engaged with the one that's wounded.
[SPEAKER_06]: Wait, did he turn to hit me?
[SPEAKER_06]: That's the one that turned to hit me?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, you got attacked by that one.
[SPEAKER_03]: Fucking six plus... Nine?
[SPEAKER_03]: Plus nine is fifteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_03]: Dagger, 10, plus 9 is 19.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_03]: You have a sick attack?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: Plus 3, so 1 die 4, 1 die 4 plus 6.
[SPEAKER_03]: There is 2, plus 6 is 8, plus 8 is 16, 17, 18.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sixty-six points of damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you distract with your scimitar and then stab the dude.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's attack and bonus.
[SPEAKER_04]: You want to move or try to move at all or just go head-to-head with this guy?
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I...
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know if I can sidestep over to here or not.
[SPEAKER_03]: You could sidestep to there, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to sidestep just to open it up.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's Gouge.
[SPEAKER_02]: This guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ooh, no, he can't move to there.
[SPEAKER_04]: He attacks you, Gouge.
[SPEAKER_04]: First attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: 17.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: He does...
[SPEAKER_04]: Eight plus seven is fifteen points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Uncanny dodge!
[SPEAKER_04]: You take seven points of damage?
[SPEAKER_03]: Fuck me.
[SPEAKER_03]: And the next attack is three.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twelve a miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, you're lucky there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, that's his turn.
[SPEAKER_04]: Jude, what do you do?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to fireball both their asses.
[SPEAKER_01]: How many people can I protect with my meta magic?
[SPEAKER_04]: It is the spell level.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus your modifier for your intelligence.
[SPEAKER_04]: Which is four, so up to seven?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so that's no problem because I mean there's one, two, I can even help myself three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: So there's only... Yeah, basically you can put the fireball down and just fly them.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm gonna put the fireball down right between so it catches both these guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so they're gonna have to make...
[SPEAKER_01]: Remind me again on human determination.
[SPEAKER_04]: You get to take any roll you want at advantage if you want to.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_01]: And a 20 foot radius, so that gets both of those guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's make a Dexterity saving throw.
[SPEAKER_01]: Target takes 8d6 fire damage on a failed save or half as much damage on a successful one.
[SPEAKER_01]: A successful save.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it can spread around corners, so that's all.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you lay down the fireball?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, Jude raises his hand with flames in it, about to throw down, and that guy snaps his fingers and the flame goes out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fucker!
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to move?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I move out of his sight.
[SPEAKER_01]: No smoking in here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right into there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Still behind the wall?
[SPEAKER_01]: Does that cover me?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's covered.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're covered.
[SPEAKER_04]: I use cover.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's Jude.
[SPEAKER_04]: Merrick.
[SPEAKER_03]: I yell grapple his ass!
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh yeah, you need his hands tied in.
[SPEAKER_04]: You got your bow?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_05]: Move back here.
[SPEAKER_05]: Uh-huh.
[SPEAKER_05]: Is he visible for me to shoot an arrow?
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can fire him.
[SPEAKER_05]: Take him to the ground!
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, I'm doing a bonus action.
[SPEAKER_05]: This will be my last spell as well.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hunter's Mark on the one that I can hit.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: And then I'm going to shoot an arrow.
[SPEAKER_03]: Does he have advantage or no?
[SPEAKER_03]: No advantage.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I'm just shooting an arrow.
[SPEAKER_05]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_05]: A nine.
[SPEAKER_05]: A nine plus...
[SPEAKER_05]: The seven of my attack bonus, is that what it is?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: So sixteen.
[SPEAKER_05]: That is a hit.
[SPEAKER_05]: So one die eight plus two die six.
[SPEAKER_05]: Names and Names.
[SPEAKER_05]: Names and Names and Names and Names.
[SPEAKER_04]: Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names and Names
[SPEAKER_04]: What's the mark do?
[SPEAKER_03]: It does an extra 1.6 damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, that was what it was.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, the arrow hits him in the side, and it's a solid hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: And the guy falls to his knees.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's going down.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Who else?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, everybody's been down.
[SPEAKER_06]: Everybody's been down.
[SPEAKER_03]: Turkey.
[SPEAKER_03]: 19 for Gouge.
[SPEAKER_04]: 11 for you, Merrick?
[SPEAKER_01]: 8.
[SPEAKER_04]: 8 for you, Paul?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: Tyrus, what'd you get?
[SPEAKER_04]: 14.
[SPEAKER_04]: 21.
[SPEAKER_04]: Jude gets 21.
[SPEAKER_01]: Folsum, what'd you get?
[SPEAKER_04]: 9.
[SPEAKER_04]: 9?
[SPEAKER_04]: That one gets a 17.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's done though.
[SPEAKER_04]: That one gets a 4-12.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right, so Jude is first.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, this is my strategy.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm gonna move here, and I'm gonna cast Fireball right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm hoping he doesn't even see me cast.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm gonna plant it right there, still assuming that he's right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: So another fireball, I'll bend it around everybody that I can.
[SPEAKER_04]: So Jude comes up and goes, flame sprouts at your feet.
[SPEAKER_04]: Strangely, it just bends around your body.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eight, nine, six.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so there's one, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_03]: Got him.
[SPEAKER_01]: 6, 7, oh I need one more.
[SPEAKER_01]: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
[SPEAKER_01]: 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 16 plus 10, 26, 29.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can he die?
[SPEAKER_01]: How many did you have?
[SPEAKER_00]: Here's his saving throw.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a dexterity saving throw.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four, and your DC is a 15, I think it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: 15 or 16.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, that does not save.
[SPEAKER_04]: So he takes all 29 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nice!
[SPEAKER_04]: Alright, so that was Jude.
[SPEAKER_04]: No way he's left.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're eight, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, the guy in the middle just dropped and hit the ground, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: You're 14.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, he's dropping.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, 80?
[SPEAKER_01]: That guy is also, if he can... That guy's dropped.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wipe him off.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, he's toasting.
[SPEAKER_04]: Scout, it's your turn.
[SPEAKER_04]: I want to engage him if I can.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you want to walk there, you and Tyrus can both fight him.
[SPEAKER_06]: There and there, or just here?
[SPEAKER_06]: You can go into there.
[SPEAKER_06]: Is there another opening?
[SPEAKER_06]: This is another opening where Gouge is at, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: Over here.
[SPEAKER_04]: There is another opening over there.
[SPEAKER_06]: You could go all the way around almost, couldn't you?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, where was I?
[SPEAKER_04]: You were right there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right here?
[SPEAKER_04]: Right here.
[SPEAKER_04]: So if you wanted to, you could go in that way.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, leave it clear.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I was right here?
[SPEAKER_03]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_03]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a table in there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you see anybody else in that room?
[SPEAKER_01]: Any chairs?
[SPEAKER_01]: And you see Lord Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tie up in a chair right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You better have a ball gag in.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to attack him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to use my human determination on my scimitar attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: So, advantage.
[SPEAKER_06]: He was engaged in Mealer's ground.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thirteen, and?
[SPEAKER_03]: Fifteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Fifteen plus attack?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, nine.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you want a sneak attack?
[SPEAKER_03]: I do.
[SPEAKER_03]: So that's the three die six plus a one die six plus six.
[SPEAKER_03]: So that's nine, ten, thirteen, nineteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nineteen points of damage.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_04]: And my dagger, 47 off him.
[SPEAKER_04]: 14, 23.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_06]: One die four.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Three, nine.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nine, that's 56 off him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so that's Gouge.
[SPEAKER_03]: Jude is gone.
[SPEAKER_04]: He gets to go.
[SPEAKER_04]: Who got the 14?
[SPEAKER_05]: That's me.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's Tyrus, but he's got a 17.
[SPEAKER_04]: He disengages and goes 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 to here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Don't let him go away.
[SPEAKER_05]: I thought the guy who was 17 was the one who got smoked.
[SPEAKER_05]: No.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, it was.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, you're right.
[SPEAKER_04]: He does have 12.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, you're right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Good call, Brett.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, it is Tyrus gets to go.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_06]: This guy hasn't been doing magic shit, has he?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, he was the one that went to Jude.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: So, I'm going to go for a grapple right here.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm gonna go for taking him down.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you wanna try and grapple him?
[SPEAKER_03]: Grab him, now he can attack you if you grab him, he just can't move.
[SPEAKER_06]: Right, I can attack, wait.
[SPEAKER_04]: So if you grapple, you both can attack each other.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_06]: But he can't move.
[SPEAKER_06]: But I'll be on top of him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, you won't have your shield, but you'll have him right there and you'll be like...
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, I mean, can I take him to the ground though?
[SPEAKER_06]: You could shove him, you could try to shove him prone, but you wouldn't grapple him if that was the case.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, I'm going to grapple him then and hold onto him.
[SPEAKER_06]: Fifteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fifteen, what is your strength bonus?
[SPEAKER_04]: Athletics actually is what it is.
[SPEAKER_06]: Athletics is plus two, or wait, athletics is plus five.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus five, so that's twenty, here's his roll.
[SPEAKER_04]: At 16, he manages to avoid your grasp.
[SPEAKER_06]: Now wait, can I roll this then?
[SPEAKER_06]: Absolutely you can.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, so I'm going to use that.
[SPEAKER_06]: Does this add to my roll then?
[SPEAKER_04]: It adds everything to your roll.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh my gosh.
[SPEAKER_04]: I got a little too excited.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, that's good!
[SPEAKER_04]: That actually gets it.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think it gives you the advantage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes!
[SPEAKER_04]: So basically you grab onto that guy with your action.
[SPEAKER_06]: Awesome.
[SPEAKER_06]: And now I get to hit him, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: We both attack.
[SPEAKER_06]: What can you do with your bonus action?
[SPEAKER_06]: That was your attack action.
[SPEAKER_06]: So my bonus action, I can... Oh wait.
[SPEAKER_06]: I can.
[SPEAKER_06]: Bite?
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can cast a Wrathful Smite spell and have that stored up for the next round.
[SPEAKER_06]: I didn't know that would go for the next round.
[SPEAKER_06]: It could last for 10 rounds.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you can store it up.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's Bard, Ranger, and are we talking Paladin over here?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, alright, so then now we've got...
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, I thought that was part of that deal.
[SPEAKER_06]: You keep strange company these days.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm gonna cast Thunderous Smite.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, so he grabs him with his left hand.
[SPEAKER_04]: His left hand, and then he's like charging up his thunderous smite, his sword is glowing, he's ready to smack him real hard.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: That'll be next round.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Now I'm getting the hang of that.
[SPEAKER_06]: His turn.
[SPEAKER_04]: He basically stabs you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Repeatedly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Seven plus
[SPEAKER_04]: Nine is 16.
[SPEAKER_04]: What's your AC?
[SPEAKER_04]: Eighteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eighteen, but you don't have your shield.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sixteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two plus seven is nine points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: He stabs you again.
[SPEAKER_03]: One, and misses.
[SPEAKER_03]: I took seven total.
[SPEAKER_00]: Seven total, and... Yeah, okay, he does not lose his thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Would I have been able to use cutting words to what were the...
[SPEAKER_00]: The initial roll on his hit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it like a reaction?
[SPEAKER_04]: You can use cutting words now.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like your bardic inspiration in reverse.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you can do a bonus action and do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Could I have done my bonus action to make sure... Only on your turn.
[SPEAKER_00]: Only on my turn, gotcha.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you can throw it out this turn, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: That'll affect his next roll?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um, so Tyrus is gone.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you start singing in, like, sharts and- That guy is gone.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's just like, uh, it's Marry's turn.
[SPEAKER_03]: I've been with him, he just kinda does a-
[SPEAKER_05]: Since my Hunter's Mark, I killed or dropped that first one.
[SPEAKER_05]: And it automatically goes to him, I believe.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can go one, two, three, four, see him, bonus action, put it on him, and action attacks.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think it was bonus action that moves him or did it automatically move to him?
[SPEAKER_04]: You have to bonus action save who it goes to.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's what the bonus action is.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I move there, bonus action on him.
[SPEAKER_05]: Am I too close to shoot or should I not?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, you can fire.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, I can fire.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm just gonna fire.
[SPEAKER_05]: Is he still holding him?
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, I'm gonna fire on him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ooh, does that restrict the guy's dex?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, for his armor?
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, his dex AC?
[SPEAKER_05]: He can't move.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's all it says.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's all it does.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, I'm shooting right at him.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's a turkey.
[SPEAKER_05]: Uh, sixteen.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ooh, that's a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sixteen plus.
[SPEAKER_05]: Uh, seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: One die six and one die eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus your bonus.
[SPEAKER_03]: Two total?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Plus your bonus.
[SPEAKER_05]: Two.
[SPEAKER_05]: What damage?
[SPEAKER_05]: That's plus three with the bonus.
[SPEAKER_04]: So five.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sixty-one.
[SPEAKER_04]: You point right at his eyeball and he moves out of the way and skims his face.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is Merrick Folsom.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I am going to...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to run over to Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three.
[SPEAKER_00]: And can I see the guy attacking?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can't, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because he's grappled with Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I'm just going to dash and go more this way and get over towards.
[SPEAKER_04]: So one, two, three, four, five, six, and you want to go six again?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, over towards.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_06]: Ooh, you could be really helpful there.
[SPEAKER_06]: I also run up on it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to be that guy, but Kitten Words is a reaction.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cutting Words is a reaction to a role.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, is it?
[SPEAKER_00]: You should have told me.
[SPEAKER_04]: I was looking at it.
[SPEAKER_04]: I apologize.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't know much about Cutting Words, but that's even more awesome.
[SPEAKER_04]: You could have stayed then.
[SPEAKER_03]: Please be that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't mind you quoting rules to me.
[SPEAKER_04]: I can't know everything from everything.
[SPEAKER_04]: People need to know their characters.
[SPEAKER_03]: I've learned in the game Noon 2, there's so much new shit I've got to remember everything.
[SPEAKER_04]: But if you know your character, you could do a lot better, because I can't remember RPG games.
[SPEAKER_04]: I was going to say, I play as very certain classes.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've never played as a rogue before.
[SPEAKER_02]: Whose turn?
[SPEAKER_04]: It is an ish.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did I actually play as a ranger?
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't think I went.
[SPEAKER_04]: I had a low one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, you did.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're right, Jude.
[SPEAKER_04]: You haven't gone.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: 5, 10, 15, 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I see him from here?
[SPEAKER_04]: Man down!
[SPEAKER_04]: Even though he's on the ground?
[SPEAKER_04]: He's not on the ground.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's being held.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tyrus has it with his left hand, and he's holding his sword up.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to cast him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Can we get a grip on Fairwind?
[SPEAKER_04]: Is he just standing there?
[SPEAKER_04]: So Suggestion in combat gives him bonus, he gets advantage in saving throws.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is it because it's combat?
[SPEAKER_03]: Because it's combat.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he's not like listening to you, he's... No, so what it is, is what I'm banking on is like if he's a wizard, he might have low wisdom, so even with advantage...
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll still try it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so I'm gonna cast Suggestion.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's... What's your DC?
[SPEAKER_01]: Where do we write down DC?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's under the spell stuff?
[SPEAKER_01]: Sixteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it's a wisdom.
[SPEAKER_01]: Savings, right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it's a wisdom.
[SPEAKER_01]: So let me double-check that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Suggestion.
[SPEAKER_06]: Those cards are cool, the spells that are in those.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I like that.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I'm getting citadels.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah, no, they're... You can get different kinds of cards for each class, whatever.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you don't have to read through that.
[SPEAKER_01]: With some saving cards on a failed save, it pursues the course of the action that you described.
[SPEAKER_01]: To the best of its ability.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so word what your suggestion is.
[SPEAKER_01]: I say, surrender now!
[SPEAKER_04]: You don't want to be like, I suggest you surrender and cooperate completely with all of us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Or something like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I suggest that you surrender and help us in all of our endeavors.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gives a plus four, so he has to roll a twelve at disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_04]: At advantage.
[SPEAKER_04]: He says, despite your lack of spellcasting ability, I would love to surrender now, if possible, and cooperate in all possible ways.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's looking up at Tyrus's...
[SPEAKER_04]: Giant sword, and I'll smack him right in the face.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll be like...
[SPEAKER_04]: I absolutely surrender, and I will cooperate.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're the best of my ability.
[SPEAKER_04]: Despite the mumbling...
[SPEAKER_04]: Despite the mumbling, bumbling...
[SPEAKER_01]: Even though I deeply insult him.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, Anish, I guess.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know if everybody's gonna let us surrender.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was gonna say, I'm debating on if we take him back with us.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm ready.
[SPEAKER_06]: If that guy wiggles his frickin' fingers or twitches or does anything... Whatever the case, you have your action ready.
[SPEAKER_04]: If he moves, you're gonna smack him.
[SPEAKER_06]: If he moves, he does anything wrong.
[SPEAKER_06]: Nish?
[SPEAKER_04]: I was afraid of that.
[SPEAKER_04]: 16.
[SPEAKER_04]: Uh, 20.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, wait, Gouge was... 16.
[SPEAKER_06]: Fourteen for Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fourteen for Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're here.
[SPEAKER_04]: You are twenty?
[SPEAKER_03]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_03]: I got seventeen.
[SPEAKER_03]: What are you, Folsum?
[SPEAKER_03]: Twenty-one.
[SPEAKER_03]: Twenty-one?
[SPEAKER_04]: Seventeen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Seventeen?
[SPEAKER_03]: I got five.
[SPEAKER_06]: You thought he was going to surrender.
[SPEAKER_04]: You thought they were going to let him surrender.
[SPEAKER_04]: And for him, he gets eleven, eighteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, Folsum is first.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, I'm going to one, it's six, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Zap him in the head.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm really thinking about using Charm Person on Gouge so he doesn't kill you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Poor suggestion.
[SPEAKER_00]: I suggest we let him surrender.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, maybe my suggestion can work on the rest of my career.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was gonna say, I don't think we should kill him, but I...
[SPEAKER_00]: Despite the ineptitude of your reaction, you're all tied up.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we're positive that he's alright?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's not turned or anything like that?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, we don't know that.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's evil.
[SPEAKER_00]: You better roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to...
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: We can't metagame too much.
[SPEAKER_02]: Doesn't matter, he needs to be with us alive.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna cast Charm Person on this game.
[SPEAKER_01]: Charm Person?
[SPEAKER_00]: Charm Person just to me.
[SPEAKER_05]: Alright, you cast Charm Person.
[SPEAKER_05]: He looks up at you and goes, what a wonderful mustache.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you have a mustache?
[SPEAKER_00]: I do have a mustache.
[SPEAKER_03]: Like a Robin Hood hat and a mustache.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna try it.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're all...
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Who's next?
[SPEAKER_00]: The next person to go is Paul.
[SPEAKER_04]: He could hear what's going on.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to basically tell them to let this guy surrender or what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll take him alive.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's what I say.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so Paul, do you want to do anything else?
[SPEAKER_01]: Hold an action or whatever?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll just walk into the room right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, we already know that he's holding an action, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: I am ready to smite this guy into oblivion.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, no, can I like handcuff him or something?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so Paul walks in and basically says, we'll take him alive.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy gets to go next, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: And he smiles up at you, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: And he goes, you heard your prince, you will take me alive.
[SPEAKER_04]: Shut the hell up.
[SPEAKER_04]: He readies an action in case you do something.
[SPEAKER_04]: Which is gonna be a dodge, okay?
[SPEAKER_04]: Basically.
[SPEAKER_04]: The next person in line is Jude.
[SPEAKER_04]: Strip him of all of his stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I was gonna say I sweep in and I take his hands and I put them behind his back.
[SPEAKER_01]: I bind him like any wizard needs to be bound.
[SPEAKER_01]: Verbal.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So Jude comes up and says, Tyrus, let me take care of this, and you let him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, you've got a shoulder.
[SPEAKER_04]: Jude can do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Jude takes his rapier, puts his hand behind his back.
[SPEAKER_02]: The last thing I'll do is gag him for it.
[SPEAKER_02]: No verbal, no verbal.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gouge.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, I would like to stay with my scimitar and what is the, in this new rules, is there a subdue?
[SPEAKER_03]: You want to just knock them out?
[SPEAKER_03]: I want to knock them out.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's no real rule for that.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, you could attack him until he's unconscious.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't want to stab him or anything.
[SPEAKER_03]: You want to just punch him in the face until he goes down?
[SPEAKER_03]: Or try for a pommel of my scimitar on the head?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, because that might kill him.
[SPEAKER_02]: It could kill him.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would prefer if he is alive as the best of rich in Geo.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna punch him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gouge steps forward and smacks him in the face.
[SPEAKER_04]: Attack with advantage, because he's being held, and four.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eight plus your strength.
[SPEAKER_03]: Strength, and I got a plus four on that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Twelve.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you walk up and punch him in the stomach.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: It doesn't do anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does he act like he just got a kidney?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, he goes, uh!
[SPEAKER_04]: But that's about it.
[SPEAKER_03]: I can't have an offhand punch?
[SPEAKER_04]: Want to stop the other one?
[SPEAKER_01]: I look at the big guy, and I'm all like... Nine, thirteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: At advantage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_04]: Natural 20?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so double damage, which is two points of damage, plus six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Then you punch him in the kidney, and he drops to his knees.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not unconscious, okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: I spin him around to the floor, and I'm all like, get him on.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know that I can get a whole lot of Gouge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just hold on to the guy.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm just holding on to the guy.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to make sure when he like... Do I still have movement?
[SPEAKER_04]: Gouge!
[SPEAKER_04]: Tyrus, it's your turn.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to grab the guy and stick him in a chair?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I want to... Can I finish with movement?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is me?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: How many do I get?
[SPEAKER_03]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was gonna say, if you guys can grab Fairwind and bring him into this... You hop up on the table and walk over.
[SPEAKER_01]: Stand up over Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_01]: Look at him.
[SPEAKER_03]: I will shoot my web.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can we strip points?
[SPEAKER_06]: So can I just drag this guy out of the doorway and just into...
[SPEAKER_06]: There are chairs right there.
[SPEAKER_06]: Can we slap him into a chair?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you drag him over there, throw him down in a chair.
[SPEAKER_04]: Strip him down.
[SPEAKER_04]: I want him...
[SPEAKER_06]: He's already been stripped.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I'll do the searching.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know how to search him, especially for secret pouches or pockets.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was gonna say it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't want him pulling the wizard's bullshit up.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want his chair facing your wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I want him, like, you know, basically, like, just facing the wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I want him tied to the chair.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like I said, I'm gonna go ahead and stuff like anything, like his own, if I have to rip his own clothing or my own or whatever, I want his hands full so he can't like do cymbals.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you go over there and rip his silken shirt around his shoulders and down to his arms and tie them behind.
[SPEAKER_04]: His Toli finery is completely ruined by this grubby elf's hands.
[SPEAKER_01]: These guys sound like my hands are grubby.
[SPEAKER_04]: He whispers grubby elf at Sewell, not thinking that you know the language, as you tie it behind him and shove him towards the ball.
[SPEAKER_04]: Shut up, you filthy pig.
[SPEAKER_04]: He kind of looks at you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Kind of looks at you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Merrick, what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_05]: You want to go punch a guy?
[SPEAKER_03]: You already feel good.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm coming in.
[SPEAKER_05]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_05]: One.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to yell over my shoulder also.
[SPEAKER_01]: Make sure that we're secure.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was gonna say, can we spread out and get this room locked down?